(lively Music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is Laura D'Andrea Tyson,
who is the class of 1939.
Professor of Economics and
Business at UC Berkeley.
In the first Clinton administration,
she served as National
Economic Council chair
and as chairperson of the
Council of Economic Advisors.
Before going to Washington Professor Tyson
served as director of the
Institute of International Studies
and was a founding director
of the Berkeley Roundtable
on the International Economy.
Her publications include
Who's Bashing Whom,
Trade Conflict in High
Technology Industries.
Laura, welcome back to Berkeley.
- Thank you very much.
- How did your growing up years
prepare you for the road
toward public service.
I got to ask you that.
- My growing up here years?
- Yes.
- Well, I think the main
thing for me was somewhere
I suppose between high school and college
or certainly in college.
I really was thinking about public policy.
So those were the kinds of
issues that interested me
and it never interested
me to run for office.
I wanna emphasize, that's not what I mean.
I didn't ever even run
for a school office.
But it did interest me to
try to figure out a way
to address some national
issues like poverty
or international trade or whatever.
And that was true from pretty early on.
- And I gather, you were
good at math basically
that was one of the skills,
yeah.
- I was.
Yes I was good at math.
But at a certain point I wanted
to find a way to use math
to link it to these public policy concerns
rather than math for its own sake.
- In the accounts of your
service in Washington,
I'm gonna flatter you,
now you're described as,
"Standing your ground and
policy debates, a great educator
"or politicians and the public
and a person who doesn't
"take things personally."
Without making you blush
and if you will accept
those compliments, how
are those skills honed?
Basically what do you think?
- Well, you know I had an ideal job
for an academic in Washington.
My job really was to give economic advice.
I didn't run any programs,
and I wasn't after any office.
So the only thing I had
to offer was my advice
and I took that very seriously.
I thought that when I went into a room,
if I didn't say what I thought
or what my profession thought
about an issue, that I wasn't doing my job
even if what I said was not politically,
easy for the listeners to accept.
- So this gave you a focus?
- It gave me a definition, a
job definition and a focus.
And I said to myself many times,
"If I don't give this advice
then I'm not doing my job."
I also said, "If I'm not
credible, if I go out
"and speak publicly but I speak in a way
"which is not believable then
I will be of much less value
"to the administration."
So that allowed me to hold
my ground in terms of saying
what I thought rather than
what someone told me to say.
- And why did you go into economics?
- Well, I could always get
back to the math question.
I was looking for a way to
take my interest in mathematics
and my interest in sort of
analytical ways of thinking
about the world and apply
them in a public policy arena.
And when I took an economics class
in sophomore year of college,
I realized almost instantly that
this was the right connection.
It's a very analytical way of
thinking, logic, scientific.
You can use a fair amount
of math in it if you want
but it was all about the kinds of issues
that in my sort of private life,
I worried a lot about or read a lot about.
- And you went to MIT?
- Yes I did.
- Were there a lot of women
going into economics at MIT
when you were there or were
they just starting to be more?
- There were many, there
were many fewer than today.
I think in the class of about nearly 30,
there were four women who started,
one who dropped out very quickly.
So for three of us finished
and actually the three of us
are full-fledged practicing economists.
What was different about MIT,
I had gone to a woman's
college, Smith College
and of course there was no such
thing as a male discipline.
All disciplines were by
definition female disciplines.
When I got to MIT, I
was old enough I guess
that it didn't bother me
too much that my class
was primarily all of a sudden men.
The issue really was that
MIT was a much more abstract
and theoretical approach to economics
than Smith College had been.
So I had to make a kind of transition
to a different kind of economics.
Now many graduates, many
students in economics
have to make that transition.
Undergraduate, the way you teach
undergraduates in economics
and the way you teach graduate
school is quite different.
- And who did you study under at MIT?
- Well, I studied under a
very, a great group of people,
a professor named Evsey
Domar who actually was expert
on the Soviet Union, at the time called
the Soviet Union of course.
I was very interested in
comparative economics,
how other societies handle
the same economic problems
as the United States.
He became a great mentor
and supporter of mine.
I worked with a young faculty member,
very new to the field named Duncan Foley
who is still in the
field and was excellent,
in terms of again his wife
was getting a PhD at Harvard
and he was very supportive
of women in PhD programs.
And then some of the
big names in the field,
in addition I worked with
Bob Solow and Les Thurow.
- And when did you get
into political economy?
Which I guess even in your early work
is something you--
- I think I was always
in political economy.
I always thought when I
went to graduate school
that I was going to
study economics to apply
to policy political problems.
In fact when I went to
graduate school in economics,
I thought very seriously
about going to public policy
instead, almost did, almost went
to get a public policy degree instead.
And when I was at graduate
school, my intention really
was to work for an organization
like the World Bank
or the International Monetary Fund.
So my goal was always to use
economics as a discipline
to address certain policy challenges.
- One of the skills that
you developed somewhere here
and I wanna ask you about that,
is a capacity to communicate clearly
about what are often very
dense and complicated issues
especially writing about them.
We'll talk about some of
your recent Op-Ed pieces.
But where did you learn that?
How was that skill honed?
- Well I do believe that you
can learn things by practice.
And I first learned how to
be clear about economics
through teaching.
Now I think one thing
that helped me frankly
was that economics was not
an easy discipline for me.
It was a challenging discipline.
It was something that I had
to think about seriously
and convince myself that
I could follow the logic.
So because of that, because in some sense
it wasn't intuitive for me,
I have been I guess quite likely
when I sit down with someone
to do it step by step
because that's how I understand it.
And I hone those skills
by just doing classes,
class after class.
You know I started teaching in 1973,
and I got better.
Now as far as writing is
concerned, that also is something
which comes with practice.
I don't think I'm a sort of,
it's not easy for me to write.
Some people can sit down
and just sort of polish something off.
I tend to write so that the
first version is very close
to the last version.
And so I agonize over,
particularly over introductions,
first paragraphs.
But again I worked for a while,
I served on the board of
editors of the Los Angeles Times
and therefore I was writing
about every six weeks
and I just got better.
I also frankly learned some
pointers from my husband
who is a professional writer.
And when I started doing
Op-Ed pieces for the LA Times,
he was very helpful to me,
in terms of thinking about structure
and grabbing introductory
sentences, things like that.
- Do you also have models
in great economists
who also were great writers?
- Well, I think there have
been some very gifted writers
among my profession.
They tend to be rare,
and they're very gifted.
I would not compare myself to them.
If you take John Maynard
Keynes and you go back
and read some of his work,
I just quoted something
of his in an Op-Ed piece
I'm working on about the
Asian financial crisis.
And it's a beautiful quote.
And John Kenneth Galbraith
is a modern version
in the sense of being someone
who really has the ability
to write literature, who's
also writing economics.
I aspire two I think clarity.
(laughs)
- Right.
Okay, was it hard
starting out in economics
once you have your degree
because you were a woman?
Was there any discrimination, latent
or not latent that you encountered?
- Well, I actually think in my own life
because of timing that I was helped
by being a woman on balance.
It's different, it is
different but clearly for me
I came into the graduate program
and entered the job market
for economists at a time when
there was increasing attention
being paid to the issue of getting women
into the profession.
So I think that clearly my first job,
when I, even going back to MIT,
when I was admitted to MIT,
I was the first student who
had ever been admitted MIT
from Smith College.
I think MIT thought they were
basically taking a chance.
They were gonna see if a very good student
from Smith College a
summa cum laude student
from Smith College could
make it in that program.
And they, so I feel in
several points in my life
being a woman has been helpful to me
in terms of attracting
someone's attention,
"Okay we could take a chance."
Now with that of course
you then have to make
the most of the chance.
You have to show people,
yes, you can do it.
And so that really is,
I feel quite comfortable
with the view even with President Clinton.
That when I met him, I was
of interest to him in part
because he'd really wanted
to have a diverse cabinet
but frankly I ended working well for him
not because I was a woman
but because of my abilities
to deal with economic issues.
Are there downsides to being a woman?
You know it's just different,
I mean I would say just as an example,
we used to have White House
meetings at 7:30 in the morning.
And the way Leon Panetta ran the meetings,
they tended to oftentimes be
a kind of people jumping in.
In general, women are
less adept or less willing
to just jump into conversations.
I think they're more likely to do better
in structured conversations.
So that's an example of a negative.
I think that it's still the case today
that if you sort of look at the press
and look at how many times women
are quoted versus men, things like that.
That there is a tendency still
to perceive power and wisdom
more with men than women.
But on balance, I think it's
been a positive in my life.
- So but in a way you're saying
that even an administration
like the Clinton administration
which was very committed
to filling roles with
women that there still
are structural problems,
and once they're cemented,
then you're judged
on your merit basically,
is that a fair, yes?
- Well, it's that I would
say structural as well as
they're almost behavioral issues
- Behavioral, okay yeah.
- I mean
men and women I do
believe behave differently
in some respects.
And there are these interesting books by
- Tenha.
- Yes, right on sort of how women and men
handle conversation differently
and handle words differently and meeting.
She actually has some very
interesting discussions
of meetings which I
think captured very much
the kind of difference
that I mentioned before.
- Substantively when you started out,
you really were working
on the Yugoslavia economy
and issues related to the changes
in Eastern European economy
In planned economies
- In planned economies.
- But by the time you went to Washington
you were really working on
issues of competitiveness,
Industrial Policy, comparative
but also very much focused
on the United States.
Tell us a little about that
- How did that happen?
- Transition, yeah.
Were you still committed to
the same subjects in a way
but you wound up just moving
to a different subject?
- Well, I was always interested
in international issues.
So much of the work I
did on Eastern Europe
was about its trade,
about foreign investment,
about its relationships with
the International Monetary Fund,
about how it responded to its
international debt crisis.
So there was always an
international component.
The second thing is that I was interested
in sort of big national comparisons
like how do countries compare on savings
and investment rates or
how they handle inflation
or how they try to
generate an economic system
which supports low levels of unemployment.
So you can ask these kinds
of questions in any setting.
You can ask them in a planned economy,
how do they do that, and you can ask it
in a in England or France.
So I started to teach more
broadly on comparative.
These broad comparative issues
and I started to move out of just talking
about Soviet Union in Central Europe
to talking about Western
Europe and then to Asia.
And I started doing some joint teaching
with colleague of mine
that you know John Zysman
who I had known in graduate school
He and I had been at MIT.
He was in political
science, I was in economics.
We started to team teach or
teach one another's classes.
He was very interested in Western Europe
and that got me interested
and thinking about
these kinds of competitive comparisons
among advanced industrial countries.
And frankly back when
I made this transition
which was really in the early 1980s.
It was still almost a decade
before anything really started
to happen in Central Europe
and I was getting a little bored.
I mean I understood the problems,
I think people didn't
understand the problems
and basically they're in terms
of solving economic problems,
there was a just a
tremendous political barrier
to making any forward steps.
So it was also lack of interest
in what I have been doing.
- How did you wind up in Washington?
- Well, that really involves I think
the phenomenon of networks
in the United States
or in any society.
First of all, I think that
my choice of graduate school
was very important to
everything that happened
to me thereafter.
MIT is a wonderful,
it has an outstanding reputation
in the field of economics.
Its students are very well
placed at the best institutions
around the country.
So I first had a job at Princeton,
then I had a job at Berkeley.
I started to develop my reputation
for being both an effective teacher
and for asking interesting questions.
That led to my being invited
at a certain point to teach
for a year at MIT and
then to teach for a year
at the Harvard Business School.
And at the Harvard Business
School, I got to know Bob Bryce
who became Secretary of Labor,
was a very close friend of the Clintons
and it was really that
network which led me
to being introduced to the president
when he was a candidate.
And from there on, I mean,
it really took on the issue
of what kind of cabinet did he want,
what kind of economic advice did he want,
who did he feel comfortable with.
- How would you
characterize the differences
between the realm of
politics and public service,
and the realm of academic life?
I mean here you were a
professor at Berkeley
and all that conjures up and
then for the next four years,
you're in the middle at
the very top in Washington.
What was the difference here?
- Well, my husband claims and
I guess I would agree with him
that my ability to get
through in Washington,
my ability to do well in
Washington was not predict,
was not really predictable.
I mean I really didn't have
any experience or history
which would have suggested I
would go into this environment
of sort of political figures
and convince them that I
had reason to be in the room
or convince them that I had
reason to be at the table.
I think that, again I would
go back to the special nature
of my assignments there.
I felt that what I did in the university
which was to explain economics,
to explain trade-offs,
to try to, I never try in my teaching
to tell people the right thing to do.
I try to help people develop the logic
to make that decision on their own.
So a lot of what I try
to do in the classroom
or what I tried to do increasingly
I did some consulting
before I went to Washington.
And when I tried to do with
business leaders was to explain
the economic trade-offs and help them
think through a decision.
And I just did the same
thing in Washington.
And the I guess the other
thing that was true is that
I did believe
and somehow this may be
about who I am as a person.
I certainly believed in what we were doing
and because I believed
in what we were doing,
I was very energetic
and able to defend it,
to explain it, to try to convince people
that we were doing the right thing.
- Now, in the profiles I read of you,
one of the things that stood out
from your early years was
cheerleading and numbers.
- Cheerleading in numbers.
- And what you just said
may say that you developed
some skills back there.
And I mean both in a positive way.
- Right, I understand.
Well, on the cheerleading
thing, I will only say one thing
that I will never forget,
it's a very interesting fact.
When I was just finished
with graduate school,
the National Science
Foundation had a conference
and they invited women who had gotten PhDs
in "Scientific" fields
from the previous five to seven years
to come to Washington and
talk about their experience.
What made them get a PhD in a scientific
therefore a male-dominated field.
And these women did not
have that much in common
but I want to tell you that the majority,
the vast majority of them
had been cheerleaders.
Now what does that tell you?
I think it tells you that
when these women had grown up,
it was still prior to
competitive sports for women.
There were no teams for
women, there was none.
So what women did who sort
of wanted to be competitive,
wanted to be sort of out
there and sort of involved
with the school and
sort of part of the team
was cheerleading
(Laura laughs)
So it may say something
about my competitive nature,
it may say something
about my outgoing nature,
it may say something about my ability
to associate with a team.
I was considered a team
player in Washington.
And the numbers well I don't know you know
that's just something that
I don't quite understand.
I always enjoyed math but not
so much that I was willing
to basically commit my entire life to it.
- But we've just disapproved
your husband in a way.
There were things in your
background that you know,
that's right.
In Washington, you earned a reputation
as a communicator and an analyst.
And one of the things you were
quoted as saying in a profile
that I read is that, "What you
do best is present the facts
"and odds with public perception."
That you felt very
comfortable in that role.
Let's talk about your
reactions and your experiences
in confronting the irrational
symbolic side of politics
where people really don't
want to look at the evidence,
they don't want to look at the facts.
- Well, I think that I had different roles
in the administration.
I did a lot of representing
the administration
with national media.
And the print media and
the television media.
And there I felt that
as I mentioned before,
the key thing was
credibility and therefore
that if I presented the facts
and tried to present them
in a clear and unbiased way
and tried to defend my
presentation when upon,
that that's what people wanted to hear.
They didn't want to have
me posturing or basically,
and you know, at one point
I went to a conference
as an administration official in Aspen
and it was a big conference,
primarily of very high
ranking Republicans.
And the speaker before me was Senator Dole
and I was the only Clinton
administration official
who was there and it was
not a supportive audience,
it was quite a hostile audience.
But I actually won over
a lot of the audience,
not that I convinced them
to change their positions
but they believed that I was honestly
trying to explain the
situation, how I understood it,
why we were doing what we were doing.
And frankly, the other
thing you need to do
as a professional economist
is recognize all the time
the limitations on our
knowledge, nothing is perfect.
So you say,
"Well we think this kind of tax increase."
that's always been the big
issue with Republicans,
"While it was not our goal to come in
"and raise taxes on the
top one and a half percent
"of the American population,
"we felt that given all of the economic
"and political constraints
that we confronted,
"the only way to get this
deficit reduction path in place
"was to accept this, it was a trade-off."
Were there cost to that?
Sure, there were political costs
and there were even some economic costs.
And if you say that to people,
so you've given them a
sort of full representation
of the situation, they're
more likely to believe you.
Now inside the halls of the administration
that approach also worked very well.
Just going in and basically
taking the arguments
and the facts and trying
to present trade-offs.
Where it worked less well
and perhaps not well at all
was in testimony before Congress.
Because the testimony before
Congress really is much more
about posturing and
criticizing or defending
than it is about explication
or understanding.
- What idea did you take to Washington?
I know that right before you went,
you had written this book
on Who's Bashing Whom.
Do you think that what
you did in Washington
on those issues was consistent
with what you had written
or did your ideas about
the way things were
changed when you were in Washington?
- Well, I think by and
large there was consistency.
I do think that you learn
when you're in that situation.
What's the limits of, what is feasible
and what is not feasible?
And the feasibility
limitations can actually be
from political constraints.
So let me sort of suggest
where it's consistent
and then some of the constraints.
Where it's consistent is if for people
there was a lot of criticism
of that book by people
who never read it.
And they claimed that I was protectionist,
that I was a sort of heavy
enthusiast of industrial policy.
Basically what the book says
is most of the U.S.
economic competitive loss
which occurred between the mid 1980s
and the early 1990s was self induced.
That the main things we should
worry about were getting
our macroeconomic house in
order, continuing to spend
on research and development,
and working to bring down trade
barriers around the world.
Not build them up here
but bring them down.
That where we had serious
bilateral conflicts
particularly with Japan
and with the Europeans,
we needed to not assume
that we would be better off
if they broke the rules or
didn't play by the rules.
We needed to recognize
that it was in our interest
to use our negotiating
policy and occasionally,
rarely but occasionally, the threat
or actual use of the sanction to get them
to change their behavior.
I think we behaved in
Washington very consistently
with all of those policy views.
Now where would I say limitations existed?
I mean just on the example
of trade policy issues,
we did develop a sectorally oriented
trade approach with Japan.
Now I would say that
there was a lot of debate
about what sectors should be
on our sectorally oriented approach.
Some sectors I think fit my notion
of what should be on
there and some didn't.
And why did ones get on that
didn't fit my sort of notion
of high technology and
research and development
and forward-looking?
Well, because there are political reasons
why things get on a list
as well as economic.
So I say that the feasibility is straight
maybe that just means
that some of the decisions
are made on economic logic
and some of them are
made on political logic.
- As you navigated this this transition
and you watched ideas that you
had in the Academy applied,
what surprised you most
about political life?
Anything in particular
about the way ideas work
their way through the system?
- Well, I can get,
I guess my, the most revealing example,
I have a couple examples,
there, back in 1993
when we were talking about
how much deficit reduction
to introduce into the
President's budget proposal.
There was a big debate
about whether we should,
whether it mattered to the economy.
If we had a $500 billion
target or $480 billion target.
And the reason this became a hot topic
was because in order to get
to the $500 billion topic
we had to do some really,
really undesirable things.
Like make the tax rate
increase retroactive.
Now I argued that
we have a six trillion dollar economy,
$20 billion over five years
is nothing, it's minuscule.
And that argument was basically,
it was overruled by the notion that
the only way we could make
this politically saleable,
this was not just the
administration's position,
it was the Democrats in Congress.
The only way we could get
the Democrats in Congress
to support us was make
it a certain figure.
A figure itself which had no
particular economic logic.
So that was that, I learned
a lot from that experience
because I would bring in all this evidence
and people will say well, and
I think that another example
which I'll just then go to 1996.
There's sort of these things which,
in 1996 we had proposed.
Someone in the Treasury had proposed
that we eliminate capital gains on housing
as a Tax Simplification measure.
Because Americans who buy houses
and do make improvements
when they sell the house,
it used to be the case
where you had to show
all your improvements,
keep all those records.
So you could show what your
actual capital gains is.
We were looking for Tax
Simplification ideas.
Well, over time over the course of 1996,
this idea moved from a
Tax Simplification idea
to a tax break.
Isn't really a tax break,
most people actually
never paid capital gains
on their house, most people
didn't even give the paperwork.
But it became a tax break
and the Republicans also
proposed a tax break.
So here's a tax proposal
which had very small significance
in terms of simplification.
It has no merit in
terms of economic effect
and it became something that
is now part of the tax code.
And the most interesting thing about that,
is this to my knowledge,
there was never any,
this was not because there
was a groundswell of support
for such a position.
This actually came from the top-down
rather than from the bottom-up,
very interesting phenomenon.
- So what was the most
important economic issue
that the Clinton administration
confronted when you came in?
The deficit?
- I think so.
I think it was, I would
put it differently,
it was how to get the U.S. economy
on a path which would take away this,
what the Congress called a
structural deficit problem.
The issue was that of course
as a result of the savings
and loan crisis and the war with Iraq,
the deficit had gotten
much bigger than anyone
had predicted.
So it was $290 billion,
that was one concern.
But the real concern was that
even if you prove the
economy with growth path
as a positive growth path,
the deficit predictions were
getting larger not smaller
which is not a sustainable position.
And it had been a position
which the US had been in
from the early 1980s.
I remember sitting in the
Institute of International Studies
in the conference room and Ronald Reagan
was elected president
with a bunch of economists
and political scientists from Berkeley.
And we talked about the
consequence of his election
was going to be big tax cuts,
big increases in military
spending and a huge deficit.
And that is what happened,
and it really was only in the
1990s more than a decade later
that the U.S. took action really
with President Clinton's leadership
to bring that problem under control.
So yes, it was the single largest problem.
- And are you surprised
by how remarkably positive
what you did was?
- Ooh sure.
I mean in the sense that I
think we did the right thing
but I think all of us were surprised
and continued to be surprised
at how well the economy has done.
I mean there's a lot
of things going on here
that we don't entirely understand.
I mean why is the inflation
rate so much lower
or why can the economy
have an unemployment rate
that's averaging below 5% and
not have cost pressure coming
from the labor market side.
Why does productivity growth
look like it's increasing?
The thing that we, our
logic was very simple
and it was that if you reduce
the deficit in a credible way
you will support more investment,
you'll create a climate
more conducive to investment
and that's good for the
economy in the long run.
But we were very careful
to tell the president
that there might not be
any dramatic benefits
in the short run.
And then there happened
and then things went much
better than expected.
- Were you surprised
by the the constraints
on the administration,
and for example dealing
with the International bond market
or was this something
that through your study
and work was not surprising to you?
Or were you that constrained by the time?
It's an assumption.
- Well, I understood it
differently which is that basically
and I think you can see the
power of global markets today,
financial markets today in Asia.
We have a world in which there
are these tremendous flows
of capital that move across borders.
They respond to their interpretation
of what nations are doing.
The U.S. freely from about
the mid-1980s till about 1994
was considered by the rest
of the global community
to be behaving in a
very irresponsible way.
Why should the largest, why
should the richest nation
in the world become the largest
debtor nation in the world?
Why were we not saving and
lending to the rest of the world
rather than borrowing from
the rest of the world.
That kind of perception
can become very powerful source of action.
And I think we believed in
that number one, the US
government was probably
at that point paying a premium
in terms of its borrowing
costs because of expectations
that its borrowing needs were
gonna get greater over time.
So we believed we could bring
long-term interest rates down,
get that premium out of there.
We frankly we were also
concerned that if we didn't do
at some point, no one could predict when,
there might be a real move
against U.S. Treasury bonds
and a real decline in the dollar
and a real spike up an interest rate.
A kind of U.S. version
of a financial crisis
which we were, which was
out there as a possibility.
- So in a way it was related
to the symbolic dimension on something.
That was not unimportant in this?
- Look markets, I think
again since we're sitting
in the middle of a
financial crisis in Asia,
one of the things that you,
that these kinds of situations
demonstrates so clearly
is that so much of this
is about confidence.
And so much of the confidence
is based on perception
rather than actual knowledge.
So people who invested heavily in Asia
up through the third quarter
of 1997, was the same systems.
Whenever, you think of the systems,
I happen to think they're very strong,
good economic fundamentals
but now you read about them,
it sounds like how could anybody
have been foolish enough
to put their money there?
Well, the perception in through
the third quarter of 1997,
was these were a great
places to put their money
and then investors lost confidence
and everybody headed for the door.
You have got to be careful
to do the right thing
and to describe what you're doing
because you could lose that confidence,
and once you lose it, it's
very hard to get back.
- Before we talk about the Asia situation
which I'd like to do,
I would like to ask you about two fronts
that as a Liberal
Democratic administration
or moderate Democratic administration.
The Clinton administration did not succeed
or was not able to control.
And that is health care
reform and income inequality.
Resolving those issues.
I don't know if the two are related
but there are some general
thoughts here about
the limits of reform
and addressing issues
that an administration
like this confronted.
- Well, I think they're different.
The reasons for the inability to address
these issues are different.
So in health I think we
did have, since health care
is about 14% of the American economy,
there are vast economic
interests that are wedded
to the current configuration
of the health care system.
And we can see that now
in the sort of pressures
that are playing out over managed care.
That doctors are threatening to unionize
and manage care providers
are under attack now for,
are they preventing necessary procedures?
So the point is there
are huge vested interests
in this part of the economy.
If you decide to take
it on sort of completely
as one fell swoop,
you are going to handle Medicare,
Medicaid, the uninsured,
cost containment and the federal
government's budget deficit
all at once.
You are going to have to
have a very elaborate plan
and you are going to mobilize
a very large number of opponents.
So we did both.
We had a very elaborate plan
that was very hard to explain to anyone.
And one of the things you certainly learn,
it goes back to our
discussion about perception
is the importance and power
of message in political life.
It's not just do you have a good policy,
it is can you explain the policy
in a very short period of time.
In essentially a soundbite period of time.
We did not have such a policy.
The second point is we did mobilize
every possible constituency
group against us.
We thought we were going to have
the leaders of large American corporations
because they were suffering
from high health care costs.
But then they looked at
the proposal and said,
"We may end up here or having to give up
"our own efforts to cut costs
"and the government
maybe is less successful.
"So we're not going to support this."
We thought we were gonna get
the absolute outstanding support
of the Medicare population
because we were gonna give them
prescription drug coverage.
But the Medicare population while
they decided to be
supportive were actually
kind of concerned because
we were gonna cut Medicare
and then kind of put the
money back in a different way.
And I could go on and on,
the insurers, the doctors,
the hospitals.
- All arrayed against you.
What about income inequality?
- So although you say-
- Yes sure, yes sure.
- I think we, in a way, we
approached it the wrong way.
Because I think a lesson
here and it's also a lesson
from the Republican revolution of 1994.
Then playing out in 1995,
is if you overreach,
if you try to do too much at once,
then you may end up
accomplishing very little.
That's the way, our system
is one of checks and balances
and marginal steps.
And except in crisis situations
and the health care
situation is now a crisis
in the United States,
it's a serious problem.
I don't think our system
is really organized
to make big steps.
Since that time of course as
you know, the administration
has achieved some successes on
health care in smaller steps.
Greater coverage of children,
insurance market reform
to help with issues of
excluding restrictions
which make it difficult for
people to get health care.
The administration brought down,
increase the tax deductibility
of health care spending
for the self-employed.
So there are a number of
things which have helped.
Now of course we have this proposal
to extend Medicare down in age
to cover people who are not yet retired
but can't get health
insurance in other way.
And we did protect the
Medicaid as a guarantee.
So there really were some
accomplishments in health.
But they're marginal,
that is the way we omit.
One should not marginal in
their entirety but incremental.
I mean that's the word is incremental.
Income inequality is a
much different issue,
the reason it's hard to deal with
is that no one entirely
understands its causes.
And the causes we do understand
are very hard to do anything about
at least in the short run.
So the theories about why
income inequality has increased
in the United States range from trade
and immigration pressures
which have probably played
some role though not nearly as
large a role as people think.
What does that mean?
It means that people at particularly
with just a high school education or less
have been competing with
unskilled workers around the world
and with unskilled workers
who have moved to the United States.
So it's put downward
pressure on their income.
A second factor, is that is
a much more powerful factor,
it seems is the changing
demands of technology.
So having a high school
education which used to be a path
to a good middle-income life is simply
that path is closed off, you can't do it.
Because that would have been familiar
through manufacturing jobs,
manufacturing productivity
has increased dramatically
but the number of people who are there
for in manufacturing jobs
has not grown rapidly.
People are moving into
self-service sector jobs
and there, there's a bifurcation.
You can have a good service sector job
if you're computer literate
or you're a software engineer
or anything to do with computers frankly.
If you're not it's much harder,
then you're gonna get
into retail services,
you're gonna get into household services
where the wages are simply not attractive
relative to high wage jobs.
So I think you have these
changes in technology,
changes in global competition
which are huge forces.
They're operating
everywhere around the world
and there's not that much
that a national policy environment can do.
I think we actually
did a number of things.
We increased, we cut
taxes for the bottom 20%
through an expansion of what's called
the Earned Income Tax Credit.
We managed to get Congress
to pass after they said
they would never do it,
a significant increase
in the minimum wage.
We have devoted, or there
is much more devoted now
to spending on education,
educational opportunity really focused at,
I would say after high school.
In a way the focus has been on now,
now it's going to preschool,
sort of certain critical moments
in the educational life of
an individual that matter
to their long-run ability
to get the skills needed
for modern technology.
- And the administration also
increased the minimum wage
which relates to the the
weakening power of the unions
which you've identified.
- The weakening power of
the unions as a real issue
I don't think that there's,
again, the reasons for that
I have a lot to do with sort of the change
in the composition of the workforce.
Because manufacturing sector
was much more unionized
than the service sectors is.
Now the current, the relatively
new AFL-CIO leadership
is trying to do more unionization
among service workers.
And frankly I think
stronger unions on balance
would help with address this
problem of income inequality.
On the other hand I think that
the American Union movement
is really in the wrong place
on issues of international trade.
So I mean I both want
them to be successful
because I think that they
have been a powerful force
for compressing inequality over time.
But I think that, I hope they become
a little more forward-looking
on trade issues.
- Tell us about what you
think is President Clinton's
most outstanding leadership quality?
Or is there something
about the way that he led
that you were heartened by
and were surprised about?
Is there something about
leadership you learned from him?
- Well,
I would say I've, a couple of things,
or points which have been
made I think are true, he.
There are certain times and
I think the budget of 1993,
the health care effort in 1994,
the effort to help Mexico
through difficult financial
circumstances in 1995
and his whole commitment
to trade liberalization
despite the opposition
of his Democratic base,
are all clear indications of both
a vision,
knowledge of what he wanted
to accomplish and character
that is a willingness to
endure serious political risk
and to do things that were unpopular.
The second point, I would
say though not though
in addition is that
he is a very gifted political figure.
And what that means is that he understands
the necessity of compromise.
And he finally would
rather get something done
than stand for something
that cannot be done.
You can commit yourself to something
that you would like to
do and talk about it
but and he does that.
It's very good, I think
because of his ability
to speak clearly and in a
very down-to-earth fashion.
I think he can really communicate
with the American people
which is another part of his skill.
But I think he also
understands that you don't
just say, well so I can't have everything
I'll take nothing.
He tried that in a sense
that was health care
that was the closest we came.
But in most other issues I
think was willing to compromise.
And some people interpreted that
to be a kind of lack of,
a lack of vision.
I honestly don't think so.
I think there's a vision
and a political ability
that work together.
- As we do this interview where
as we were mentioning earlier overtaken
by the turn of events in Asia.
And I'm curious for your thoughts about
what the dominoes apparently falling
in that region,
Thailand, Indonesia,
Korea, which were perceived
as being so strong and in some ways
as a kind of a threat to
the United States and so on.
What these, the sharp turn in events
tells us about globalization
in the management
of the international economy?
Drawing on your experience
because that's partly
what y'all dealt with
as you just described.
- Well, you know in the,
I think we dealt with this
in a much smaller I turned out easier
to contain fashion in Mexico.
And when we, it is a kind of
I think very defining moment
in terms of leadership for the president.
Because there was very
little support in the press
and very little support in the Congress
and very little support in the public
for any sort of bailout of Mexico.
What the president understood
and it was really almost instinctive,
he didn't need to be convinced,
was that U.S. interests
whether they were economic interests
or military interests
or Democratic interests
were at risk
from a destabilized Mexico
financial situation.
And that it was in the
interest of the United States
to use its capabilities for leadership
and its resources to stabilize that.
And I think that's the
same that's true now.
It's not that Japan has been
and I believe at some point
will be again a serious
competitor for the United Sates.
It is in fact still a serious
competitor for United States
if you look in particular industries.
South Korea was becoming
a serious competitor.
And I think that the
recognition of leadership
is that you want to have these
parts of the world be stable
and you want them to be prosperous.
Yeah, they may pose a competitive threat
but you're on balance much better off,
having a healthy trading partners
than you are having
debilitated trading partners.
You're much better off if you can spend
a couple billion dollars to stabilize,
to prevent a debt default in South Korea
than if South Korea
defaults and you end up
having to pick up the bill
for work that South Korea
was gonna do with North
Korea on a nuclear reactor.
So you have to I think realize
and I think the president
instinctively realizes this
that in the global system that we now live
you can't distinguish very clearly
between our military security,
our national security
and our Economic Security.
They're all part of the same system.
The second thing, I think he understands
and I think that Alan
Greenspan understands this.
And that we understood any message
from the economic team.
Is a globalization like almost
all other economic forces
has its pluses and it's minuses.
So the same technologies and
the same financial innovations
that could pull billions
of dollars of capital
into South Korea or into
Thailand in a couple years
could allow that capital to
migrate in a couple of days.
And the volatility of capital markets
and the magnitude of their
swings have both been increased
by the ability of the
system to move money around.
On the other hand, on the
good side just think about
all the investment
opportunity that would never
have been funded in these countries
that are good investment opportunities
if the money hadn't been available.
Or think about all of
the Americans who might
have wanted to invest in these
economies that would not have
had the opportunity to do so.
So if the world is one of imperfection,
you have to take the good with the bad.
And then you always work
to make the good better
and control the bad.
- Is that your philosophy
of government actually?
(laugh)
- My philosophy of government is that
you know some people went to Washington
and I think their experience in Washington
probably left them frustrated
because they had hoped
to get to closer to their
ideal of whatever it is
they wanted to accomplish.
My own sense was I went with
some doubt that much could be accomplished
and I felt that relative
to the constraints
we actually did on
balance the right thing.
So I left feeling probably
at least is positive
if not more positive
than when I first went
into the administration.
And I have friends who I
would say that's not true.
They are more frustrated, they
wanted it to be more perfect.
Maybe that is the power of economics,
economics is a dismal science.
We don't believe things are perfect.
We don't believe there are free lunches,
we believe there are trade-offs
and costs and sacrifices.
And I think that I'm gonna do
my entire introductory
economics class this spring,
all about that.
Because that is the most important insight
into policymaking, can't have it all.
- One final question, how
would you advise students
to prepare for the future and
for a role in public service
if they envision it.
- Well, I think there are,
first of all I think they need to prepare
and I think the students
I will see understand this
by a broad education
which gives them a real feel
for the rest of the world.
Because it is the case they
were so deeply embedded now
with the rest of the world.
That in order to understand the prospects
for the U.S. economy in 1998,
you do have to understand
what's happened in Asia.
And I think that one of
the goals I would have
for having an undergraduate
education at Berkeley
is at the end of that process
whether you took economics or not,
you should know enough to
be able to make those links.
So I think that is a very critical part
of living in the global economy.
I think it's also critically
important for people
to become technologically literate.
Now I have to say that for me
this is a kind of generational issue.
I'm less technologically
literate than younger people
but I'm trying to catch up.
But I think that younger people recognize
more clearly you've gotta
understand this technology.
You've gotta understand
what it can do for you
and how you can use it as a research tool.
- And what skill most
enables you to survive
in the public sector?
- Ah dear what's,
- I honestly think the ability to say
what you really think
but but to be willing to listen
to what someone else thinks.
It is if you are an ideologue,
if you are absolutely
committed to your position
then I think unless you're a politician
that is going to be a very
difficult place for you to be.
If you are a policy
person, I think you wanna,
you have to be sure that
no matter who the person
you're talking to is you
will say what you think.
But I think also you have to realize
that you need to listen back.
And also another thing is you
have to be willing to accept
the fact that you will not always prevail
no matter how intelligent
you think you are,
how powerful your arguments
are, you will lose.
And you have to say, "I fought the fight,
"I did gave my advice
and I was overruled."
- Laura thank you very
much for this very engaging
and insightful conversation on your career
and your service in the
Clinton administration.
- Thank you Harry.
- Thank you and thank you
very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(Music)